even by the standards of this war's
brutality this was a shocking attack
with ukrainian civilians bearing the
brunt the station at kramertorsk was
crowded with passengers among them many
women and children trying to get a train
to take them to safety
everyone was panicking people were
screaming and crying then i saw a
wounded woman she was bleeding heavily
parts of a missile lay nearby
[Music]
at the vive railway station in the west
the end of a journey that's taken well
over 24 hours travelling almost the
length of ukraine from kramertorsk in
the east
this train set off well before friday
morning's attack bringing people who
like the victims were trying to escape
the escalating fighting
it was a very bad situation liana tells
us all the time there was shelling and
bombing i suggest
what will you do now in la viv we ask
i've no idea she says just to get out
was the main thing
and she heads off with her children not
knowing where
in the town of bashtankar in southern
ukraine
people arrived to escape battles around
curson and mikoliath
the fighting has continued for weeks and
has now moved closer to their homes
yesterday they started shelling us they
started destroying the houses and
everything with cannons then the tanks
appeared from the forest so i decided to
leave
many displaced people head for the
relative safety of western ukraine in
the early days of the war lev railway
station and the western border crossings
were overwhelmed with hundreds of
thousands of people
as the russian advance was halted some
refugees started returning now they're
being advised to leave again
the flow of people through the station
has closely followed the course of the
war from the start and with fears of a
renewed russian offensive in the east
the viv and other cities in the west are
now bracing for a surge in people
wanting to escape the fighting
anton and arena have arrived with their
five children escaping fighting in the
southeast we stay since
russian federation start bombing our
cities we stay we wait but i just make a
decision but the first bomb
following near my house i
take my children and go away
immediately
yesterday there were two missiles shot
down near our home with shrapnel falling
outside
they plan to leave ukraine how far as
far away as possible they say rob
mcbride al jazeera level